all right a truly Blockbuster media
story Infowars conspiracy theorist Alex
Jones has been ordered to pay nearly a
billion dollars in his latest trial
flipped out started requesting money
from his audience we are going to look
at the verdicts and this is just
unbelievable the Associated Press
article on the screen lays out the
specifics Alex Jones ordered to pay
965 million dollars for his Sandy Hook
lies
jurors ordered Jones to pay nearly a
billion dollars to Sandy Hook Elementary
School shooting victims relatives and an
FBI agent who said he turned their loss
and Trauma into years of Torment by
promoting the lie that the Rampage was a
hoax this is the second big judgment
against Jones for spreading the myth
that the deadliest school shooting in
history never happened the verdict came
in a defamation suit filed by some of
the families of 26 people killed in that
2012 shooting
plus an FBI agent among the First
Responders you may recall we covered it
and spoke to lawyer Mark Bankston a
Texas jury in August awarded nearly 50
million dollars to the parents of
another slain child Robbie Parker
remember Robbie Parker lost his
six-year-old daughter Emily he's one of
the people that Alex Jones suggested was
a so-called crisis actor here is an
incredible moment the verdicts being
read in the courtroom
ladies and gentlemen of the jury please
listen to your verdict as it is right
verdict read the jury and reached our
verdicted
to be more damages to each plaintiffs
and against Alex Jones and Free Speech
Systems LLC as follows
Roman number one compensatory damages
instructions filling both numbers for
each plaintiff then go to section two
please enter your damage damages
assessments for each plaintiff on the
lines below
two plaintiff Robbie Parker a defamation
slash slander damages past the future 60
million dollars
B emotional distress damages passed to
teachers 60 million dollars wow total
fair just and reasonable damages to
Plaintiff Robert Parker and against Alex
Jones and Free Speech systems and line a
and my B total of 120 million dollars
initial by zero number one
two Plankton David wheeler a defamation
slash slander damages fast and future 25
million dollars
the emotional distress damages past and
future 30 million dollars total Fair
adjust and reasonable damages to
Plaintiff David wheeler and against Alex
Jones and Free Speech systems at line a
and 9B 55 million dollars
these verdicts continued and continued
and continued in different plaintiffs
being awarded varying amounts of money
remember what attorney Mark Bankston
told us when I interviewed him a few
weeks ago that these subsequent cases
would end Infowars they would end
Infowars now Alex Jones says that that's
not going to happen and he immediately
immediately took to the airwaves and uh
started
um asking for money essentially take a
listen to this they want to scare
everybody away from freedom and scare us
away from questioning Uvaldi and what
really happened there or Parkland or any
other event and guess what we're not
scared and we're not going away and
we're not going to stop
and literally for hundreds of thousands
of dollars I can keep them in court for
years I can appeal this stuff we can
stand up against this travesty against
the billions of dollars they want it's a
joke so please go to infowarstore.com
and get Vitamineral Fusion get X3 right
give the solution to this travesty is
getting Vitamineral Fusion
all the great products
better there that keep us on air at
infowarstore.com yeah okay so I don't
know whether this will end Infowars you
know one of the questions I had for
plaintiff's attorney Mark Bankston who
who was involved in the Texas case was
what about collecting the money okay you
got it you got a judgment you got a
verdict
how do you collect the money
he said without going into detail that
as attorneys they have ways of doing
that and that they will collect uh the
vast majority of this money now does
Alex Jones have a billion dollars not
from everything I knew
but is the whole point that the verdict
exceeds his actual assets by so much
that it will completely end Infowars now
to be clear I think it's important to
say
it's not about taking pleasure
in the financial demise of Jones or
Infowars necessarily it's more that
there has to be some responsibility for
people who have public platforms and I
include myself in this there has to be
some responsibility and accountability
and the
financial and legal problems should
correlate with the degree to which your
actions are deplorable wrong dishonest
and unethical
Jones actions over the last many years
be going Beyond even the Sandy Hook uh
Fiasco have been the lowest of the low
and so it is just that the financial and
legal consequences are uh commensurate
with that
that's the point not about cheerleading
someone's Financial ruin we will follow
it we will see what can be collected and
there are more cases coming folks this
is not the end of it
I have a really tough time finding dress
shirts I like they're either
uncomfortable or they're tight or
they're loose or hot or itchy and that's
why it's been so great to discover the
commuter shirts made by our fantastic
sponsor Rhone rhone's commuter shirt is
a reinvention of the men's dress shirt
it's the most comfortable dress shirt
I've worn Roan's comfortable four-way
stretch fabric provides the
breathability and the flexibility that
leaves you free to enjoy what life
throws your way could be a long day at
work could be brunch with the family
you're just going to be comfortable and
that's so important with rhone's wrinkle
release technology the wrinkles
disappear as you stretch and wear the
shirt which is very convenient and Rhone
is 100 machine washable so you can skip
the dry cleaning altogether I've had a
great experience with Rhone the shirts
are appropriate if you want to look nice
or somewhat formal
I rarely need to and they're just as
good as a comfortable t-shirt when you
want to relax or just move around in it
go to rhone.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman to get 20 off the most
comfortable shirt you'll ever own the
link is down below